Se desarrolló como una plegaria con movimiento
para la lluvia y la fertilidad
y la prosperidad que estas conllevaban para una sociedad agrícola.
Los bailarines, hombres y mujeres,
se ofrecían a los templos,
donde servían como puentes vivientes entre el cielo y la tierra.
Sus cuerpos bailando llevaban las plegarias de la gente a los dioses,
y la voluntad de las deidades se transmitía a través de ellos
a la gente y la tierra.
Hay muchas curvas en la danza jemer.
Se nos arquea la espalda,
las rodillas se tuercen,
se nos doblan los dedos de los pies,
los codos están hiperflexionados
y los dedos se doblan para atrás.
Todas estas curvas crean una impresión serpentina
y es importante porque, antes de que aparecieran las religiones principales,
los jemeres y otra gente por todo el mundo practicaba el animismo.
Según estas creencias, las serpientes eran muy importantes
porque, en su movimiento fluido y curvilíneo,
imitaban la corriente del agua,
así que, para invocar a la serpiente en tu cuerpo durante el baile,
tenías que evocar la imagen de ríos atravesando la Tierra:
inspirar la corriente de las aguas que dan vida.
Como pueden ver,
la danza clásica jemer es una transformación de la naturaleza,
tanto del mundo físico que nos rodea como de nuestro propio universo interno.
Tenemos cuatro principales gestos con la mano.
¿Los hacemos juntos?
¿Sí? Vale.
Esto es un árbol.
Ese árbol crecerá,
y entonces tendrá hojas.
Tras las hojas,
tendrá flores
y, tras las flores,
tendrá frutos.
Ese fruto caerá
y crecerá un nuevo árbol.
Y esos cuatro gestos
son el ciclo de la vida.
Estos cuatro gestos se usan
para crear toda una lengua con la que los bailarines se expresan.
Por ejemplo,
puedo decir,
"yo".
"Yo".
En danza sería...
O puedo decir...
"Eh, tú, ven aquí, ven aquí".
En danza...
"Ven aquí"
o "Vete, vete".
(Risas)
"Vete".
Y todo, desde...
el amor...
hasta la tristeza,
hasta...
(Zapatea)
la rabia
pueden expresarse también a través de la danza.
Hay algo de magia
en la forma en la que se filtran, se transforman y se juntan las cosas
para crear posibilidades ilimitadas en el arte.
La palabra jemer para arte,
silapak,
de hecho, originalmente significa "magia".
El artista,
el silapakar,
o el silapakarani,
es prácticamente un mago.
Me enorgullece decir
que provengo de un extenso linaje de magos,
desde mi profesora, Sophiline Cheam Shapiro,
a sus profesores, que eran estrellas en el palacio real,
a los antiguos bailarines de Angkor
y los primeros aldeanos
que fueron los que crearon esta forma artística.
Dicho esto,
en una ocasión, nuestra querida herencia casi se destruyó.
Si llevan gafas,
por favor, levántense.
Si hablan más de un idioma,
Si son blancos de piel,
por favor, levántense.
Sus gafas significaron que pueden permitirse un seguro médico.
Ese segundo o tercer idioma que hablan indica que recibieron una buena educación.
Su piel blanca significa que no tuvieron que trabajar bajo el sol.
Bajo los Jemeres Rojos,
que gobernaron Camboya de 1975 a 1979,
todos estaríamos muertos ya
debido a nuestros supuestos privilegios.
Verán,
los Jemeres Rojos miraron Camboya,
y vieron siglos de una desigualdad rígida.
El Rey y la escasa élite que lo rodeaba
tenían todos los placeres y comodidades del mundo,
mientras que la mayoritaria sufría trabajando sin descanso
en la pobreza extrema.
No necesitan un libro de historia para ver que es verdad.
La palabra jemer para "Yo",
para "mí",
es khnhom.
Esta misma palabra también significa "esclavo"
y, de hecho, a los bailarines se los conocía como knhom preah robam
o "esclavos de la danza sagrada".
Los jemeres rojos buscaban acabar con la esclavitud en Camboya,
pero, de alguna forma, para lograrlo, convirtieron a todos en esclavos.
Se convirtieron en la tiranía con la que querían acabar.
Evacuaron la capital
y arrastraron a la gente a campos de trabajo.
Destrozaron familias
y lavaron el cerebro a los niños para volverlos contra sus padres.
Había asesinatos y muertes por todas partes.
Morían por enfermedades,
exceso de trabajo,
ejecución y hambruna.
El resultado fue la pérdida de una tercera parte de la población camboyana
en menos de cuatro años
y el 90 % eran artistas de la danza jemer.
Es decir,
9 de cada 10 visiones de la tradición y el futuro se perdieron.
Afortunadamente, sin embargo,
Los profesores de mi profesora,
Chea Samy, Soth Sam On y Chheng Phon,
lideraron el resurgimiento de este arte
a partir de las cenizas de la guerra y el genocidio:
un estudiante,
un gesto,
un bailarín cada vez.
Escribieron el amor,
la magia,
la belleza,
la historia y la filosofía de nuestro linaje
en los cuerpos de la siguiente generación.
Casi 40 años después,
el baile clásico jemer ha revivido y alcanzado un nuevo nivel.
Aun así, todavía se encuentra en un entorno débil.
Las terribles consecuencias de la guerra aún acechan al pueblo jemer.
Está escrito en nuestros cuerpos,
se manifiesta en la transmisión genética del estrés postraumático
y en las familias que se enfrentan a la pobreza cíclica
y en las grandes brechas culturales y barreras de la lengua.
Pero la belleza es lo que más resiste.
La belleza tiene esta habilidad de crecer en cualquier parte y en todas partes
en cualquier momento.
La belleza es lo que conecta a la gente a través del tiempo y el espacio.
La belleza es la liberación del sufrimiento.
Conforme los artistas jemeres trabajan por revivir nuestra cultura y país,
descubrimos que hay muchos caminos con los que avanzar hacia el futuro.
Y, en una tradición en la que no solemos saber los nombres de los bailarines,
quiénes eran,
cómo eran sus vidas,
qué sentían,
voy a proponer seguir adelante honesta y abiertamente desde "khnhom".
Khnohm no como esclavo,
sino como un servicio voluntario.
Khnhom:
"Yo",
"mí",
"floreciendo".
Me llamo Prumsodun Ok.
Soy jemer
y soy estadounidense.
Soy hijo de refugiados,
un creador, un sanador
y un constructor de puentes.
Soy el primer estudiante hombre de mi profesora
en una tradición entendida por muchos como femenina
y fundé la primera compañía de baile gay camboyana.
Soy la encarnación de la belleza, los sueños y el poder
de aquellos que vinieron antes que yo.
La convergencia del pasado, el presente y el futuro
y de lo individual y lo colectivo.
Voy a interpretar el papel antiguo e intemporal
del artista como mensajero
compartiendo las palabras de Chheng Phon:
"Un jardín con solo un tipo de flor
o flores de solo un color
no es bueno".
Es un recordatorio de que nuestra fortaleza,
crecimiento,
supervivencia
e incluso existencia
tienen su pilar en la diversidad.
No obstante,
también es un mensaje de valentía.
Una flor no pide a nadie permiso para florecer.
Nació para ofrecerse al mundo.
El amor sin temores está en su naturaleza.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)